definitely go to the github repo there's
a docker file it'll make it do you like
walk you here you just it's fairly large
but it will run happy and fun but
there's also a requirement taxis know
nothing when you teach to talk about but
make sense for you guys get started on
that now I take a little bit of fun just
to check clarify you can just do the
docker run and then in this way and then
not should start for you seen this on
the next slide in fact yes if you guys
have already got doctor installed then
you should just be able to run this fast
line and that's gonna open up a jupiter
neighbor before you as well as download
the image and so just if it is quite
quite large I think we should go ahead
and do that first such time you can go
through some of the slides while it's
preparing so that'd be great you could
if just you could just run this in the
command line if you already have doctor
installed and I should get the process
kick it off so just to introduce
ourselves
my name is marcin Newcomb and the senior
scientist at Viacom where I help have
icon and bring value to all of our
social media campaigns and in the
reporting tracking and planning pays
enjoying that I come from a background
in physics where I was classically
trained is that it has a physicist where
I got my PhD last year grad center and
I'm been mikorski I'm a dear scientist
at thrive io5 we do and that's sort of
the data set using it's kind of derived
from some fresh data we provide managed
marketing services and platform services
to small and mid-sized businesses also
it's really interesting like set of data
we have data from like you know web
traffic we
data from our users activity there their
customers activity so it's a really
interesting set of problems an
interesting like population that we're
dealing with that may have very little
sophistication in digital marketing and
we sort of help give them guidance and
that's sort of a kind of the the
initiative that we're going to talk
about today is sort of out of like doing
that guidance for customers and for our
internal teams I put way too much
contact type information in there so
feel free to check out the frypot tech
blog or me on Twitter
github she also has a github but he's
not gonna put it on on the slides share
on this slide so that you can learn
because that's where the the repo for
this project so we'll go ahead and and
go back to the slide just to make sure
everyone is on the same page is there
anyone that's having trouble getting
docker up and running or has any trouble
because I think now would be a good time
to sort us out otherwise I found that in
these kind of tutorials partnering with
your family neighbor is a great way to
learn from each other as well as if
you're having issues spam as well yes
their world will pause for five minutes
and then give everyone an opportunity to
at least get things running and we can
go around the room and and debug some
issues if there are any so yeah if you
have any any issues or anything please
raise a hand and either plan and I find
the right move around and and try and
and try and resolve them
just definitely just interrupt us yeah
so some people might be having trouble
with that link for Windows
it's basically we were just trying to
give you a link for if you have Windows
and you want install docker just Google
Windows install
yeah if any okay so if anybody has
problems with Windows to use the share
with you
[Music]
yeah so if you and then his - our
requirements install but just like it
sir it's you might also need to install
and then you can just run if you do so
so quick quick note if you if you go the
requirement text route you might also
need to install Jupiter because you need
to I mean if you want to run the
notebook you're gonna need to install do
press it can actually run that's not
actually in the highest
[Applause]
okay so might be pseudo either those are
you
it's doesn't seem to show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay I think everyone's like pretty much
so much that it seemed that the Internet
is good yes so if we do have any
troubles or plans meant to get to the
notes section and we can solve that sold
out that so in this case runners that
we're gonna get started on understanding
the intuition behind why we might use
probabilistic modeling and why even
hierarchical model would be a good
option for us and so change in our world
in the business world we often get
questions from other members of the
organization maybe they're in the self
self department maybe learning analytics
and they usually are very high level and
business questions like myself person
will come to us and say hi I involve how
can I help you
I'm sorry this is a missing example time
did this so is laughing so this is an
example of maybe if I wanna try five my
vendors and that is a customer that is
is coming to them the past
about their business and how they can
increase their spend I doing a campaign
and after I fight they're experts in
this and so and they're very informal
and so an example conversation might be
as follows if I'm the salesperson hi how
can I help you and then the customer
would be I want to run I had this very
campaign how much do I spend so here
expecting kind of a range of numbers and
it's also open to interpretation as well
as today that could be many different
factors that go into answering this
problem and you want you might want to
answer this in by by opt-in kind of a
range of numbers rather than suing them
one specific number and of course if the
salesman might not know specifically
what the answer is but they will ask the
data scientist or the doneness or some
technical about knows numbers on how
they should answer this question and say
in a perfect world yeah this every sales
person would know the answer but you
know that's why we have jobs so they'll
come to us and then as the numbers
people will try and figure them out and
we'll use our historical knowledge on
the industry to try and figure I'll
answer and like ideally we'd want some
some realistic range that we could give
back to the salesperson to say and you
should try and sell this this customer
depending on their where they live or
what industry they're in how much
they're willing to spend kind of a range
of numbers that could that's almost
optimally work for them and say then the
salesperson come to us as a salesperson
usually in slack or something because
it's quite informal so an example would
be like oh I need estimate for this
company why the sell the sales persons
time telling us on the next on the next
campaign and then we'll come back to
them you
sure give me some few things that I need
to know about this company and these
would be the kind of features that would
go into my model and so like ten
features that would be relevant would be
maybe how big of a company are they if
they have a big company maybe they need
to have more outreach and so that could
require more spending where are they
located is it in a big city or a rural
area or industry or any other in as well
and so the salesperson would kind of
come back to us again and give us the
information that we can then put into
our models and then great then if we had
a traditional like black box base models
then we'd come out with one number which
which which isn't great there's no
uncertainty that is quite a big and and
in depending on what kind of model you
use it could be quite difficult to
figure out exactly why you got that
number and what features were important
into that number without doing some
diagnostic analysis on top of them on
them as well and so then the salesperson
would you usually come back because they
have some industry knowledge and say are
you sure like that doesn't sound quite
right and then you yeah that's what my
model says so obviously that's not great
and so that's why holistic modeling
could be could be an alternative
approach to this yeah just send us that
- that like - beyond just like getting
that range it's also a conversation
right like this salesperson is talking
to this customer and like being able to
like say like well we see for customers
like you here's our range right and they
might know that off the bat like the top
of their head likely they don't and so
something like a probabilistic model
where you have that built-in uncertainty
you have that built-in conversation it
might be it's way better like you have
it by nature it's a little bit better
application so much yeah I mean other
reason that probabilistic models could
what that's a is because they're
extremely flexible you can then click
whatever priors that you want or might
be appropriate which could
then impact the results that you get on
on the posterior distribution so this is
what we we kind of have we have in our
data set we have customer spend on
different marketing products and that
was courtesy of Ben from 305 so this is
real data it has been analyzed it's
noise data it's yeah it's based on real
data it's derived formula but I think
that that also points to a good part of
probabilistic models as well as because
that you can use generate data from from
from the real data so this could be
great for like an application would be
like like big strapping like results as
well as if you needed to expand your
data set then this this could be a way
that you could do it and so what we have
in order to to reduce our goal is to get
these realistic spans on how much we
should advise ourselves personally on
what else should go back to that client
with so we have customers fans of
marketing data branch from historical
data you have customer characteristics
from what kind of customers typically
spend more and so our aim is to to
produce this creative model for
estimating that spend range giving some
very high-level characteristics so this
could provide a range of predictions
which you can then skip to our to our
salesperson and it would give them the
knowledge to to make the sale
essentially
and this is one example of using
probabilistic knowledge in marketing so
many applications to it so there's a
couple that are listed here
for example if you want to look at their
lifetime value of a customer or you
wanted to do much marketing mix models
which is another application on top of
that as well as you could use it in
finance it's very popular there because
there's always some stochastic nature to
say the values of stocks and bonds let's
say so these are other alternative
applications for this kind of modeling
and so the thing I like about
probabilistic modeling is it it
describes the data that you can observe
for the system so that that's again
going back to driving this mortar then
create the data that you initially had
and so it uses Bayesian analysis to say
kind of if we know probability theory
then and Dinos some prior distributions
of maybe the specific variables then we
can use that into our model we can use
the prior knowledge that we have as
industry experts to feed into the model
and then make predictions that make
sense
okay so show of hands has anybody worked
with probabilistic model Bayes stuff
before okay cool
oh good it's like a good half of people
great so you guys can teach me so this
is the obligatory Bayes rule I haven't
seen before the basic idea behind Bayes
rule and you know I've struggled with
like kind of wrapping my head around it
the way that I try to understand it is
can we get a better prediction of the
world based on the data that we observe
can we update our predictions based on
what we actually observe that makes kind
of intuitive natural sense right that's
just what we do on a daily basis right
we you know we try and like pick up
something that's sharp and we're like oh
that's sharp and now we have data to
know to not pick up that thing again
right we do that sort of as a natural
like part of part of us and so I think
the intuition behind like the like a
probabilistic method or a Bayesian
method is like pretty intuitive even
though the stats are super super
complicated so the basic idea I won't
like like go through the entire like
Bayes rule but the idea is we have and
this might be a better way to think more
intuitively about it we have we have
some data we have a hypothesis about the
action sort of generating that data that
we can sort of build into our model we
anticipate for like in marketing's
setting we anticipate that spend is
probably going to have a probably normal
distribution right like we have a lot of
people that are spending this kind of
average ones we have some people that
are spending less we have some people
that are really are you know stellar
customers that are spending more so we
can build that knowledge into into our
model and then we have how likely the
data we observe this data given our
hypothesis about the world and that sort
of just normalized by probability of
observing the data so that's sort of
already talked about this but basically
models are not new to marketing or
generally the field they've been used in
various forms you could think of I've
seen regularization talked about as
basically like a Bayesian kind of update
or basing constraint to coefficients so
these things are already kind of in use
these are getting more and more popular
and happy to talk about any of these
things I won't dive too too deep into
them but the main power of it is being
able to include some prior information
about the hypothesis and then get in the
end sort of a kind of uncertainty
estimate around your hypothesis given
the data that you observed updating your
predictions based on the observations
so now let's complicate things even more
right so the idea of a hierarchical
model again show of hands does anyone
ever worked with like hierarchical
modeling or something like that yeah
this is you guys here you guys don't
know all this now we can talk about and
we will talk about the problems with it
for sure but again you know we talked
about incorporating some prior
information about our belief in the
world into this model another thing like
a hierarchical structure is something
that we know kind of exists a one of the
canonical examples of this is school
grades for students in schools you can
imagine a school district there are
schools there are teachers and there's
some commonality between students of one
teachers students of one school schools
of one district things like that that's
a higher right and you can build that
kind of shape into the into the model so
the idea is basically to account for
these kind of group level differences in
the lab and sort of share information
between the different groups a really
good example if you want a great
walkthrough for a lot of stuff that
we're gonna be doing this time it's
wiki's blogs that's the link right there
he's also extended this a lot and it's
just a really great walkthrough in the
example that he uses is 100 gell-mann's
examples which is estimating the
relationship between having a basement
basement and radon levels and at home
I think it's an across a bunch of
different counties in Missouri believe
it's Missouri and so he goes through
three different kind of approaches
there's the non-hierarchical which is
this will give like a good grounding of
like what higher is versus like
non-hierarchical so the typical approach
which is just a pool model you're
estimating maybe one intercept one beta
for the relationship between having a
basement and and radon levels york you
have like one estimate for each of those
parameters but if you think about that
that doesn't particularly make sense
because counties are different a little
bit and you know maybe basements are
less deep where there's a higher radon
levels by nature in certain counties
there's information at the county level
that you're so we're just like kind of
climbing together in this pool that's
why it's called pool you're just sort of
pulling together into this model and so
it's not it doesn't make particularly
the most sense
so maybe what you might go to the far
other side which is making a nun pool
model where you just have completely
separate regressions for every county
and also that probably doesn't make
sense because even though the counties
are somewhat different there's probably
some similarity in the relationship
between having a basement on right on
levels and radon levels like generally
sort of baseline so you might find the
middle which is partially pool model
which is the hierarchical model which is
what we're calling the higher R come on
and basically that is you're estimating
a interest up in alpha and a beta for
each county in this in this example for
each level in the data and so you can do
a hierarchal model and it doesn't have
to be like a Bayesian hierarchical model
but the thing that sort of makes it a
Bayesian hierarchical model or a
probabilistic Rho model is your actually
imposing sort of a shared prior on these
different parameters which is we've
talked about how that's sort of it's
sort of useful to have them filled in
some like knowledge some institutional
knowledge into your model so all this is
basically making a model that better
is the world that you're kind of looking
at the world that your data it's kind of
comes from and there's also supplier I
keep hierarchies as well there's not
this region and encounter level but
think of life maybe like in the calendar
month like the region versus weekday
that might have a different outcome on
the on the prediction addresses in
summer buses in winter so there's like
there's also you can add into your
models that I've have experience with as
well what these words are like they have
like concept of what you sort of place
these together cuz I'm always on the
exact people so from my end I've heard
like a little bit of back and forth on
this some from my understanding a mixed
model you could also sort of call these
mixed models but the the hierarchy part
is that there's actually some kind of
like hierarchical structure built into
it so for those of you who haven't
worked with mixed models mixed models
are kind of like a similar thing where
you allow us to mate sort of different
parameters for different you know groups
or yeah you estimate different primers
for different groups so it's kind of a
similar thing the hierarchy part is that
there's actually like a hierarchical
structure that things tend to and it's
not always the case in the higher you
structure things tend to nest into each
other like the example about schools is
probably a little bit more intuitive
when you're trying to think of
hierarchies because a school district a
school and a teacher those things sort
of fit into each other a little bit more
there's a lot more to it I'm glossing
over a lot and there's a lot of like
back and forth whether a higher
like the same as a mixed model but you
could see that they're there the way
that they're estimated the way the users
is pretty similar so hopefully that
answers your question yeah so I won't
dig too deep into this honestly because
the blog post does a much better job but
one of the like the powerful things that
the powerful things are about these
probabilistic models are something
things that we mentioned before you have
some prior knowledge incorporated into
the model and in in these hierarchal and
a hierarchical probabilistic model
you're sharing that knowledge across the
different levels right these are this
visual on the right I think just does a
really good job of demonstrating the
power of a hierarchical model versus
sort of like the individual approach was
the fool fully unpooled approach where
you have like a separate regression for
every different county and the blue
lines are samples from that fully on
pool the green lines are sampled from
the hierarchical model and you can see
that the this is the relationship
between having a basement and radon
levels on ending up going far into this
and I wasn't intending on it but you
could see that the relationship is
fairly it was more consistent across
these different counties and that's even
in the presence of like outliers like
this one even in the presence of in this
county you actually don't have any
observations for houses that don't have
a basement and you can see the unpooled
model it's kind of like all over the
place the relationship is not it's just
then it's different it's like exists
sometimes it doesn't exist with
hierarchical model it finds this
relationship it's pretty consistent
maybe it shifts a little bit but because
there's information shared across the
counties you can do a little bit better
job of like extracting that relationship
in the Thrive context and I think this
applies to a lot of marketing context
our customers spend varies by things
like what product that they're they're
actually buying what location that
they're in you can imagine that the
Northeast is a little bit more expensive
to market to than the Midwest but
there's that kind of structure about
like there's the high spenders low
spenders and a bunch people just like
jammed in the middle that sort of
structure is shared across products and
shared across different regions and so
building that sharing that knowledge
between the different groups is
important the groups are different but
they have some commonalities between
them yes and I just said that so yeah so
that's I think the power of combining
probabilistic thinking with the
hierarchical thinking
well I think maybe we should start
meeting for service I feel like we start
yeah sorry we'll get the notebook
eventually promise just give you really
just a view of the data this is derived
from thrive 5 data we have a few
different products we have five
different products there I'll talk a
little bit about those products happy to
go into more detail but I don't want to
like spend all the time just talking
about the marketing products but people
who are familiar with kind of marketing
products might already recognize these
and then there's region and so the two
levels that we're going to be actually
using or testing in this hierarchical
approach is product level and region
level and the idea is to actually
predict spend right like going back to
that example way back the problem
statement right they want to know what
is the spend for a particular company
for a particular region for a particular
product and what is the sort of the
range of spends we might expect we want
to build that generative model to be
able to provide a sort of conversation
starter for sales and speaking to these
these customers and then we have
industry data and size data also
included in there yes yeah so this is
what I was talking about where I'm not
gonna dive too deep into it but there's
details in the notebook as well these
details are also available in notebook
but these are the some products that
we're going to be examining the thing
that I'm gonna we're gonna just call out
a couple of times is we have some idea
based on our own institutional knowledge
what we should be seeing from a
generative model and it's sort of shown
in this kind of cleaned up box plot over
here generally customers that use
display advertising campaigns tend to be
smaller they tend to be a little bit
less of sophisticated customers if a
customer has a display campaign it tends
to be an add-on to something else so
it's usually a like a lower spend
for search engine marketing search
engine marketing is whenever you like
use Google or Bing or something like
that you see and pop up like this is a
sponsored ad that's search engine
marketing search engine marketing is the
thing that's responsible for that tends
to be more expensive tends to be larger
clients that use that service and so we
expect to see that SEM is going to be on
a larger spend range display it's obably
gonna be on the lower spend range the
other ones are sort of distributed
within that also I might even call out
that search engine optimization is kind
of a little bit of a fuzzier service
because it includes sometimes like
content generation sometimes it just
includes cleaning up your meta tags and
things like that there's a lot of
different services that fall under this
umbrella and they're a lot more custom
so what we actually expect to see is a
little bit of like a wide distribution
of spends for SEO so I can talk more
about that if you're interested but I
think we should get to their own stuff
the fun stuff
that's 13 cases
working in terms of looking at the
figure it out yeah if anybody is okay
I'm sort of jumping ahead I'm sort of
jumping ahead I'm gonna just dump that
because it's so there's this is way way
way you're jumping ahead but bear with
me there's this part of the code where
you're actually running the model so
that takes a little bit of time if you
want to speed it up and make all the
statisticians in the room angry at you
just change this argument to chains one
because that'll just run one sampler
it'll make it about one-fourth the time
but I can talk about whether I'm in town
yeah but it's yeah they think they wrote
it oh yeah
you just do they buy the fall bit
smaller than that you should be fine I
think yeah I think you have to like
specify that they should run in parallel
okay well it just take it takes longer
right like so this is this goes up to it
should be 4,000 it goes up to 16,000
what 1600 sorry there's this four chains
into Java yeah yeah if you guys have
worked with IMC and like parallelizing
feel free to like switch and tweak those
that's a really quick fix for making it
run a little faster also if you want to
make it even run even faster and have
terrible results you can reduce the
numbers here but sorry so I was jumping
ahead because if you want to run the
models start the running the models now
that's probably makes sense because if
you start running them when we actually
get to them might not it might be the
end of the session you're still gonna be
running them but we'll we have the
results here right so we can go through
them and go through what you'll see but
yeah let's go I don't know what the
change that those the sampler is the
thing that so the data that you're gonna
load in that's from the repo or from the
doc file this is sort of a key to what
those variables sort of mean don't know
if there's anything particularly people
the people have any questions about that
I mean it's just sort of the
documentation just go through it so this
is the same sort of descriptives that I
had before it might be a bit different
from what I showed up there because this
is a sample or a generated sample of the
data
oh I should mention this is based on
real data which means it's not like we
didn't sanitize it or anything that's
why it's it's I think that makes a
little bit more interesting because like
I feel like a lot of the tutorials like
I've seen used like a constructed or
sanitized data set this is based on real
data and that it's like a noise version
of real data so that's okay so we're
gonna try three different things three
different models here we have the pool
model we have the product level model
and then we're gonna have a product and
region level model and the level is
basically we're just going to estimate
an interest a alpha for each of those
levels we're not going to include
actually estimating a data for each of
those of the holes this is just this is
like a kind of first cut analysis tool
model sort of looks like what we kind of
expect I just split out the different
betas because just so it's easier to
like read in the end you can basically
this is essentially equivalent to just
having a normal prior on all of the
different pages sorry I'm jumping around
a little bit but we're using eunuch Gao
seein priors for basically everything
why did we choose that because it's
simpler we can there's a lot of
different thought and has anyone did
anyone go to the Bayesian either the
beginner or master class during this yes
so that workflow is probably the
workflow that you want to apply a lot of
thinking about what is the prior
information that you're gonna include
but if your interest is to try and run
the model and see that I can test out
these methods and see what they are
results that you can't get this is a
pretty uninformative prior that will
behave pretty well in in sampling so
basically we're inputting uninformative
priors on here and you'll see how that
sort of shakes out actually it can they
for the next part
[Music]
yeah yeah it's something that I've seen
used there wasn't a lot of thought that
will have catchiest fat tails so allows
you to have yeah so maybe yeah so it
formed it performed well when I when I
first ran it so I was just like okay so
right this is gonna be focused on like
an implementation will actually get as a
teaser toward the end look at like a
possible method for like turning this
into a production prediction method so
focus is on like getting results that
getting through a full work to the
workflow oh cool so you see in the
pooled model we just have one intercept
before everything in the product level
now we have a product level intercept
which is this product alphas we also
impose some things that are something to
refer to as hyper priors there basically
we replace where we have up here we've
hard-coded sort of the mean and the
standard deviation is easier on one here
we think we have them as random
variables that are also estimated by the
model that's a little bit more in line
with how these models are usually done
just hard coding like a unit standard
deviation is usually not the best
practice but we'll actually see how that
a little bit can complicate things and
then product and region is a similar
thing where we just have an alpha for
product and alpha for region
now you'll see all these you see all
these like all this math well kind of
math and you're like how do we actually
turn this into something that is gonna
be processed that can be run that's
actually the the model that's in the in
the that actually gets sampled from and
the answer is pi MC is great and
basically you can write almost exactly
what you have up there into the PI MC
context of whether PI MC works as you
initially initialize a model instance
and then you just basically specify all
of the different rent variables and
their priors and whatever other
information you want to include not
included in here you can also have it do
some calculations like what is the
difference in means or something like
that do some other sort of any kind of
like mathematical kind of derivation you
want it to do it can do in the model
context and allow put that as a result
of the of the model and what else
yeah so the thing that we're trying to
predict here is spend and we feed it the
observed data so this is the when we go
back if you think all the way back to
that sort of Bayesian framework this is
the data part that we're giving them
giving the the model and then we just
put it into a dictionary so that's like
this sort of is how IMC works you
initialize a model context and then you
can define all the random variables and
that's what you need to have to set up
the model structure itself and then
comes the fun part
and then it's talking about how the
sampler works you want to go back to the
so I won't dive too deep into the
methods also because we're bringing a
little bit short of time but basically
how you actually get the posterior which
is the distribution that you sort of
want out of within that Bayesian
framework right the thing that was the
probability the hypothesis upon earlier
the hypothesis given the observations
that you have is through a sampling
process called Markov chain Monte Carlo
broken-down right there there's a couple
of different algorithms for doing that
the basic idea is the algorithm is going
to propose a new value for that
parameter and it's either gonna accept
it or reject it based on whether it
increases the likelihood of the data
being observed and sometimes except even
the ones that decrease the likelihood
with some probability if that's which
makes sense I love this visualization
this github page has a lot of really
cool visualizations and takes it takes
you through a lot of the algorithms
definitely recommend it if you want to
take a little bit further into the
algorithms the way the sort of default
that gets assigned
by pi MC for our sampler is called the
no u-turn sampler it is based on some
physics concepts that I very very
loosely can Congrats but the idea is
instead of like each individual like
supposing a point thinking about it
proposing a point it actually sends this
sampler sort of into a probability space
and it takes a bunch of samples and like
sort of loses its its energy the way if
I pretty intuitively explained is like a
puck going through like like a pit like
this and so you send it down here it can
move very quickly through these areas of
high probability and camp very smooth up
these walls very much and so it loses
energy and sort of stops its its motion
and so that tends to speed up the
process versus metropolis Hastings
method
the end result being that you have a
sampler this that is like pulling from
this posterior distribution that you're
trying to estimate and it'll sort of
like move through these different values
as it's sort of samples does that make
sense I have a hand wave my way through
that but take that as a yes that makes
total sense we should go back to that
so what PI MC gives you as one of their
trace plots or what's called a trace
plot is this really interesting visual
of the sampling process so remember what
I was saying about it like moves from
point to point
this is what that kind of looks like it
moved here moved here like what you
typically want to see is that it's doing
a good job of exploring the space it's
not getting stuck in any values
particularly I can show you if we have
time what it looks like when it failed
miserably but this actually looks pretty
pretty good pretty reasonable and then
you also get on the left here these are
the posterior the posterior is for those
different product betas posterior first
size and 4/4 region here the acceptance
probability error I have some details
about what those errors sort of mean
very quickly there's a there's these
these numbers up here sorry and I said I
was going to actually explain these so
there's the number of traces the number
of tuning steps and the number of chains
those are not all the options that are
available to you in the sampler but
these ones are sort of the things that
are required the tuning steps is
basically the sample is gonna run for
this many samples and that's going to
sort of tune the parameters of the rest
of the Sandpoint so it's gonna run a
thousand times and sort of tune a number
of different parameters
[Applause]
what kind of so visit there's a bunch of
different parameters I don't eat I don't
have off the top of my head all of them
the one that's relevant to this error
that we're getting here is it tunes how
far how ambitious the sampler is gonna
be like if the step size is gonna be
huge or the step size it's gonna be a
little little tiny if it's tiny and it's
more likely to accept the the proposal
of the new step but it's going to take a
long time to get any results that are
good or reasonable if it jumps it's
going to reject a lot more but it
probably will explore the space a little
bit more quickly does that sort of make
sense that's the one that's relevant to
that there's a ton of other things that
can go and do the tuning things and I
definitely could not tell you everything
is that the warm-up area like this
so I don't know I haven't heard warm up
period yeah I've heard it you heard
called birdies all right yeah I've heard
it called burnin before but yeah the
trace is the actual number of samples
post the tuning that it's gonna run the
chains is how many samplers it's going
to run the defaults I think is four then
it runs but I forcing it to do one it
just goes a little bit faster I can hear
everybody's computer to struggling right
now so at four so is gonna be 4,000 so
this one ran with four so it's 16,000
samples so it's like four yeah so it
takes some time this this stuff takes a
little bit of time yeah you can speed it
up but like speeding it up also you get
results can be a little bit volatile so
the acceptance probability so the target
is the thing that's tuned during the
during the tuning step and so the actual
number of proposed jumps was like the
percentage of them was 80% of them were
accepted and it was looking for about
90% so you can change that value as well
you can also like specify what the
exceptions probability is gonna be with
the same sort of caveats right if you
accept more of them it might if you
accept more of them it's going to do
some more ambitious moves
if you accept less of them it's going to
sort of be a little bit more
conservative and there's caveats to all
those things that are all like a set of
blog post by smarter people than me is
very gentleman look online what
so I don't usually like pre-specify that
I usually use the tuning thing and so
when it's what it recommends where you
have more tuning tuning steps I would
probably do that but again this is
there's a time trade-off right like say
if you want to get to some results you
might want to try and just you know a
lot of the vaisyas that I've heard talk
tend to be more focused less focused on
these like single metrics I'm more
focused on is this like model like is
this model like look like what we expect
right have we created a generative model
of the universe right
so that's the thing that I think
Diagnostics like like just kind of a
visual like look a qualitative look with
you and from people that are involved in
the process might be better than actual
just single metrics
yes I'm not gonna talk too much about
these so this is the the baseline model
right so yeah we're let's move on a
little bit so now we're gonna talk about
the product level where we have these
product level
alphas and we have these hyper priors
specified again the sampler looks pretty
pretty reasonable like it looks like
it's exploring this place pretty well it
doesn't look like it gets stuck in any
particular region here's where I want to
like actually look at the posterior z--
for these product alphas I don't have it
labeled here unfortunately but this is
the posterior for search engine
marketing and these two are email and
display this is sort of remember we had
talked about before that display tends
to be a smaller spend product SEM tends
to be a higher spend product this is a
that's really like the simplification of
things but this suggests that we're not
completely way off of what we might
expect the posterior don't completely
like not match with the reality of the
situation that we're dealing with so
somebody doesn't understand this you
know this
can you put a little more color on why
this actually looks intuitive and in
terms of this is what we expense because
I see or what do you mean it looks like
we expenses one higher lower that's
really it like I'm I'm giving it very
simple like read on this and there's a
lot we're gonna dig a little bit into
the actual like what the predictions
actually look like and how those match
with the reality but literally like this
is a good time to stop and check and see
if that the posterior is that you're
estimating and so these posterior it's a
good point
these posterior is particularly are like
the intercept for the product level
right this is where it kind of starts
right like if all other things are set
to zero this is where this is the
anticipated span or this is the the
range of anticipated
fans so you won't expect that displaying
and also email which is also long low
spend to be lower than SEM and you'd
expect those curves to be pretty far
apart from each other so your units on
the excess because you're saying in the
function yeah sorry so this is log this
is log dollars bet yeah so the next the
x-axes are not labeled here the trace
plot doesn't naturally like label them
but you can express the different parts
of the plot and use them in a way that
just about zero yeah you know I mean
it's this it's the same axis across the
x axis the same across the board across
all these things so they're all dollars
sorry you're right no you're absolutely
right no right so these Mu Alpha mu beta
are not because those are the hyper
priors I'm sorry about that no it's a
good it's a really good question and
thanks for for stopping me at that at
that point but those are the hyper
priors that you're putting on the Alpha
and the beta parameters so gosh I don't
know what you did all those x axes as
just probably no values that make sense
right the expected right yeah yeah cool
yeah I like that okay yeah so it's
suspected right it's the expected value
of the different distributions to the
alphas and the beta's so remember what
you were hard coding it in the pooled
model is zero and one so now we have a
distribution of what those news and
Sigma's kind of look like
okay so not anything particularly else
the call-out this is then the hierarchal
product and region now so here's where I
ended up actually removing the hyper
tires on the region and we'll talk about
that if we have time if you try and run
it with those you'll see the sampler
leads to some like wacky results and
again just like it's not particularly
good practice to just like strip them
out and like force it to be at these
different values it's better to like
actually it like examine like why the
sampler is getting stuck in certain
regions and why the sampler is giving
you weird results but this this this is
to sort of get to an end point that we
can kind of that we can use did you a
question yes just enough we just widened
maybe we just want to buy the deeper
super region oh this was Region V yes
what else
yeah so okay yeah so I wanted to also
point out these are kind of interesting
so so on both of these ends I'll just
mention again these two scales are log
dollars so this is the product alphas
that we remember from the last one we
saw a little bit more of like a spread
these seems to be a little bit more
tighter together and here's our region
alphas that so does anybody see anything
problematic about this can anybody tell
me that there's like what this how we
might interpret this I mean it
essentially means that in this case
every region is spending the same amount
approximately which seems
way to hell up this wool yeah I mean so
that's a one way of interpreting and I
interpreted as region doesn't provide
particularly useful information that's
how I read it
right and that makes I think intuitive
sense because region is these are like
before for census regions that's like
way too high level right as if people
have worked with like marketing did or
any data that like has like a sort of
geographical nature to it before like
you probably like you zip code level
stuff or you probably like like even
extract from zip code like what is the
population density you know what is the
urban or Urbanus of the area those are
the sort of things that you're a little
bit more focused on rather than like
what region that they fall into so how I
interpret this is that region is not
informative
and I think that's why the the sampler
kind of has problems with it why do you
say the reasons that the sampler has
problems with it just because it's all
over the place I think this Sam this
sample those traces I mean you know it
seems like it gets stuck in certain
regions here but I can show you what it
looks like when you include the hyper
priors right and it's then how I
interpret why it starts having a hard
time as it's trying to fit a very
complex model on no information and so
then the sampler just doesn't have
anywhere to go or it's not easy for it
to choose somewhere to go so for the
product it is the trace it's a question
um
from what I've seen it it it's that's
okay right because uh sensibly it should
be if there's some evidence that it
should be going off in a certain
direction just to start going off in
that direction it may just be that that
that is the like this the space that the
the number of values are the most likely
values that that parameter is going to
take I've seen a number of these
different race plots and having a narrow
band is not particularly a problem it
might just be that the distribution is
now or right but it's a good question
and like I think it'll actually things
will start making a little bit more
sense if we get to the actual
predictions yeah well so the evaluation
metrics will go over when does this end
oh well we have plenty of that huh okay
so maybe we should go back to the
okay so so we've looked qualitatively
and I as I said a lot of these things
from what I from my experience it's
sometimes it's just a matter of looking
at the generative model that you've
assembled and seeing like how it
actually matches your the world but
there are metrics that you can apply
there's a whole suite of metrics that
you can apply to see how good your
models doing it's sort of fitting the
world one of the ones that I've seen
used and uses a sort of Bayesian
intuition for forming its conclusions is
the W AIC which works a little bit like
the AIC that people have worked with
where a lower number is that is the
thing that you want to see out of it
basically very high level that the
there's a lot more information in these
and these sources by the way I don't
highly recommend if you wanted to dig
into these um the parent n is actually a
nice survey of Bayesian model evaluation
metrics and I thought actually pretty
accessible so I recommend it but
basically it's basically the the
likelihood of each observation penalized
by the average fare variance of the data
so when you have very small samples
obviously the variance becomes very
large and basically that's kind of
stand-in for what we look like typical
machine learning is like
cross-validation this is like you're
kind of like leaving one out and seeing
how likely that that point is based on
the model that you've sort of set up
here and I MC has WASD sort of built in
and it gives you a couple of other
metrics as well so you have the W a I
see you have the penalize W AIC which is
just penalized by the number of
parameters that you're trying to
estimate which is also pretty
informative
yeah and so we can actually see actually
run that in the notebook so yeah so what
we get out of it is this waa I see the
PWA SC the DW ase is the difference from
the lowest w AIC so you see here
actually the pool model has the lowest w
AIC but like the difference is not huge
and I kind of like the idea of including
something that splits out the different
products because based on experience
like your products are different enough
that having a single intercept probably
doesn't make the most sense and then you
can see our product region model this
has the highest W AIC so it probably
makes sense to and just looking at the
data like there's those are there's two
things right we have these metrics that
come down we have our observations and
those things together tell us that maybe
that model is probably not the model
rebar to run but you can imagine in that
principle phasing workflow that we would
you know go back try a bunch of
different types of models try different
priors see what the results are
try and run these metrics and then sort
of choose to go forward with a certain
model into the actual predictions which
is the exciting part that we're about to
dive into here so maybe go back to them
we should be back to slides
yeah so so the difference is and we sort
of talked or Matt talked about this at
the beginning we're kind of getting out
as a prediction is not like a point
estimate for each observation we're not
just saying like here's the the value it
was what was it you had like twenty five
thousand or something like that er yeah
twelve thousand or something though that
might be an example of your output from
a black box model but for the Bayesian
approach obviously you got a probability
distribution which can be a lot more
interpretive and interpretive and you
can then give that to another member of
your organization and they can do what
they want with that I mean it gives them
uncertainty level as well as a way to
kind of you know just manage their
expectations on one having one number
which puts a lot of emphasis on kind of
yeah yeah and so yeah y-you got out of
Bayesian workflow as you get this
predictive distribution versus this
predictive just isn't like prediction
and then you can sample from that
predictive distribution right that
predictive distribution is kind of that
generative model that we're sort of or I
guess the model is the generative model
but that predict distribution is the
sort of result of that generative
distribution these are the actual like
expected values of spent for every
customer that's every observation that's
in the sample so you can sample from
that distribution and it's a powerful to
actually like look at that and compare
it to like the actual real-world
distribution which we'll do in
sorry guys I just on the predictions -
just - one thing that I do a whole bunch
of sampling - like train the model do
you more sampling - predictions so it's
so it's not you're not sampling in the
same it's not you're not sampling in the
same way right you your model that
you've like derived from that sampling
process enables you to create this
predictive distribution and then you're
just pulling from that some predictive
distribution and you're sampling from
that particular distribution that you've
created right you're not you're not
actually changing the internal values of
the model the model is now designed and
now you're you're pulling out the pepino
and see your end stuff you just think oh
random number generator much like you
would randomly sample from a normal
issue yeah this is an interesting way of
thinking about it yeah it's not like a
random number generator right because a
sensibly you've you've made a good model
but yes right you're you're pulling from
it this this sort of stays how it is and
you know it fuel it'll vary like what
you'll pull out of it because it's a
distribution that you're sampling from
the distribution but the fat
distributions to sort of stay like
distribution and so when I need my
parameters because I have like two
sources of uncertainty given that maybe
I get some link the light is I have have
like some distribution in my input data
then I guess it's reflected my
parameters that is to me
and so that defines so the brothers I
guess what I sample from this consistent
look at the input data at all right it
just kind of like it kind of just as I'm
sometimes wondering like you have
uncertainty in your fujita you have
uncertainty in the progress I always
there well you're so how it's been
phrased and I really don't want to get
this wrong the data is considered an
amazing model fixed right it's not
considered to be like random like the
frequentist approaches that yeah right
the parameters are fixed and the data is
random and it's the reverse in publiced
models right so this actually is
treating the data is fixed I think I got
that arrangement right yeah so posterior
predictive checks are really exciting I
think yeah maybe we can I think it might
make sense just like show a little bit
like this is how you basically sample
from posterior
posterior and then you basically get so
I I specified I want a thousand samples
from it so you get an array back that's
a thousand samples and then it's the end
a number of observations that's in your
data so you have a basically a thousand
data sets that indepence apples from
this posterior predictive posterior and
then I just want to map some of these
just I just take like a sort of random
sample of some of these like thousand
samples that I've pulled and sort of map
that onto the actual distribution and I
kind of obfuscated this away right when
I showed you the box plot that there
these distributions are a hundred
percent not like well not a hundred
percent right a lot of these
distributions are not normal right or
not like you know like simple Gaussian
distributions
and you can see the dark lines I should
specify the dark lines here are the
actual distributions and the light lines
are the samples from the posterior
predictive distribution and so you can
see for things like SEM and SEO maybe
our posterior particular distribution is
doing a good job our model is is putting
predictions that are fairly reasonable
they seem to map on to the actual
distribution and somewhat reasonable way
but then if we start looking at display
email and social ads there's obviously a
difference there right we've enforced
and this is coming back to the problems
that I kind of alluded to before we sort
of enforce that the output is gonna be
this normal distribution and the actual
reality is it's not a normal
distribution and so it's it's trying to
the output its going to give you is it
the normal distribution that doesn't
particularly map on to the reality of
the situation so you can see a lot of
these things have these like bimodal
kind of structures and that goes back to
even within these different products
that I've sort of specified there are
products within them right there are
products that are true per share
products that are more expensive and so
having these five products I is sort of
I've obviously added away some of the
interesting information about the
products right so maybe it makes sense
that that there's it seems like there's
pretty clearly two distinct products in
display and again this comes from you're
consulting with the actual stakeholders
you can sign your culture it's
consulting with the people that are
actually generating this data so you can
make a model that is the generative
model of the data but so generally I see
from what I see here is that the the
mean of the posterior predictive
distribution doesn't seem to be way far
off from the actual values so maybe we
can output some sensible for
from this model yes
so I'm gonna do something that says it
sort of just have a nice like easily
usable metric I want to I want to test
so the thing that I actually want to
test is I wanna test are we gonna output
from this model something that a
salesperson is gonna be like that way
wrong right like that's what I kind of
want to test so I'm gonna do something
that most amazing statistics will tell
you it's totally wrong but actually just
do it like a difference in means test
and that's just the t-test that I'm
throwing throwing at this again not the
best approach not in line with actually
testing a fit of a bayesian of a
probabilistic model but if you're
looking to put something into production
the thing that you're focused on is not
giving people wildly inaccurate
predictions right and so from that
standpoint I feel like this approach
makes some amount of sense but again if
people who have gone to them went to
that basing master class he specifically
said that like looking at these
difference in means is not it's not the
way to evaluate the the the fit of your
model to the real world generating
classes so we're gonna do it anyway and
so we just take our our samples from the
posterior predictive distribution we
take the average T statistic we take the
average p-value to see like how often
eventually these are these means are
different enough from each other that we
should be concerned and you can see I
break it down again by product because I
just think that's interesting way of
looking at it D and sort of asked me to
expect SEM and SEO they seem to be
it seems like the posterior predictive
distribution fits a little bit better on
to those than it does on to something
like display and we saw that just on the
visual observation of the descriptions
[Music]
so now another fun part I guess it's all
fun parts so maybe we shouldn't let's
just jump back to the slides real quick
so actually sorry so one of the things
that we wanted to do here right like in
the actual thing that we use in
production we wanted to have some kind
of production pipeline that a
salesperson can go in plug in that you
know that situation that we outlined
before they could plug in you know I
have a customer they are a cafe they are
in the Northeast they want to display
advertising campaign where should I
start like what is the the budget range
that seems realistic for them and we
want to provide that to them without
having to just have a slack back and
forth conversation and so the solution
that we sort of went with was just like
a sort of flask application that's just
kind of internal facing and basically we
will re train this model we will save
both the model and these variables in
the form of piano shared variables to s3
and then we're able to pull that on
request and output basically a range of
predictions for that particular customer
in that particular region for that
particular product and so I'll show you
a little bit how to use that the real
power behind this really is soap IMC is
built on piano for now and piano has a
shared variables module which allows you
to sort of replace the values that are
in the computation graph like
whenever you kind of feel like and so
you can do it on request right as a
request comes in replace those values
and then the posterior predictive
distribution samples will be for those
values that you've sort of plugged into
the shared variable structure does that
kind of make sense and so we can show it
in the notebook itself so I just have
yeah so I just make a copy of the shared
variables just the maintain it I have
just a function for like reading a query
JSON and converting it to dollars in a
very simple transformation kind of way
and so I mock these this query right so
this is a display customer there in the
northeast they are you know full-service
restaurant and then I also run it for
display and then I run it for SEM and
then here's the results of an apology
that this is not labeled but this is the
actual dollars right because we just did
a simple transformation and so this is
the SEM spend range here's the display
spend range you can see that they're
very very very different and the thing
that I wanted to pull out of that like
here's sort of going all the way back to
the beginning right here's the is the
answer that you're sort of we're looking
to give your sales person right here's
the the conversation starter like okay
your this this cafe you're in the
Northeast well we see that customers
like you tend to spend you know maybe
around fifteen hundred on a campaign you
know there can be like 1,500 to 2,000
like it gives them a little bit more
power to have a conversation around the
numbers that are being generated rather
than just are like a point estimate so
that's just one way of doing this not
necessarily like this is the the best
way to deliver these deliver on the
promises of like a probabilistic model
but this is the way that we sort of you
we sort of work with sales to improve
these models and get better estimates
yeah so many questions oh it's kind of
my Christmas let me this is a I think
that's a better question for sales but
how I've heard sales people like he used
this is they're like well we see
customers like you spending like between
this and this right they can pick they
they can understand a distribution I can
understand that like this is high
there's like more people here less
people here and so they can frame the
conversation how they want right like
most people sit around here they might
you know ignore the lower spend people
and then it's like what we see people
spend up to this amount right and we can
add more information we can add like
temporal information in there say you're
you're doing a campaign in summer versus
fall and things like that we could do
yeah so I lost over that we actually
store all the predictions prior right we
don't actually run the model predictions
but it takes no time right but we wanted
to store the prediction just so we don't
have to load them on does that make
sense like there's two ways the name if
anyone went to was the shop under the
shop runner presentations they talked
about like two different ways that you
can use your flask apps in production
and it's either pre compute or have the
model like travel with your app and so
we had none'll travel with and then we
just sort of decided to switch to like
we're gonna pre compute is this range
every time we run this model and have
the the application pull on that
to precomputing every possibility yeah
there's not I mean in this situation
there's not a huge amount of
possibilities right there's all of the
different industries that we have
there's all the different regions
there's all the different products it's
not that many we're dealing with yeah
we're doing with categorical type
information okay I'm sorry I was just
curious like what are you what are your
salesman selling and they're just trying
to help it's both right like they might
want to steer them towards a certain
direction if they know something about
it or they know they want to focus on
something but a lot of are like I said a
lot of our customers are new to digital
marketing they don't know what is the
right spend and so this is a good
conversation right and they have certain
constraints that are not built into here
right like there's certain amounts that
they can't spend and the model is not it
doesn't know those yet right well we can
built those in yeah I think if you run
the pool model and do the same for the
posterior predictive text it looks worse
and that's like a qualitative sort of
top-down examination so I I think the
hierarchical model did do better but
there's a ton of information that we're
not they work encoding not particularly
much information into the the product
right we know that this product spend
looks like a certain shape where we know
something about the shape and we can
code that in to this model this is a
very very very very simple version of
what we should be
do it cool all right well if you guys
want to come up we'll chat after out of
the rumors I'm pulling out
thanks a lot thank you
[Music]